major developments again tonight on the
deep state spying on the Trump campaign
James clapper Barack Obama's former
Director of National Intelligence is
actually today saying it was a good
thing that the Trump campaign had a spy
for the FBI in their campaign during an
election I can't believe it watch it
they may had someone who was talking to
them in in the campaign but you know the
focus here and as it was with the
intelligent E is not on the campaign per
se but what the Russians were doing to
try to to instantiate themselves in the
campaign or to influence or leverage it
so if there was someone that was
observing that sort of thing well that's
a good thing yeah where was the spy in
the Hillary campaign where she did pay
for Russian lies clappers so pompous so
arrogant this is so illegal he's
actually bragging about surveilling an
opposition party during a presidential
election year if that's the case this is
not America we don't have a constitution
this is something you'd expect from the
former Soviet Union Venezuela then again
you got clappers buddy John Brennan
who's also up to his eyeballs in the
scandal probably knows a lot about it
since remember he's the guy that voted
for a communist for president last night
we had the great one Mark Levin reacting
to all of this his analysis dead spot on
take a look we have a cabal of FBI
agents who took it upon themselves to
investigate a candidate and his campaign
and then we have of course actual spies
one or more in the Trump campaign what
the hell is this the Soviet Union
Venezuela it's the United States of
America I want to know what Brennan did
I want to know what clapper did I want
to know what Comey did not because I'm
going to punish them
you'll make determinations about this
right something something is terribly
wrong we need to fix this we cannot have
in another election where the federal
government our United States government
isn't fair interfering with an election
the great ones right we've been right
everyone on this program has have been
right we need to fix it because this is
about the Constitution of the United
States and it's literally hanging in the
balance at this hour
you have unelected deep state actors
shredding our Fourth Amendment rights
your right to privacy protection against
unreasonable search and seizure this is
as I've been telling you one of the
darkest chapters in American history the
Trump campaign is targeted but there's
people like clapper Brennan Comey and
others they think that they knew better
than you did the American people about
who should be the president they've
weaponized the powerful tools of
intelligence turned it on us and they
are now politicizing differences
political differences and by the way
clapper since you're so concerned about
Russian influence in the election did
you have a spy in the Clinton campaign
now we know for a fact her campaign was
colluding had a foreign agent
Christopher Steele paying for Russian
lies and propaganda to lie to the
American people and Clinton in the DNC
remember they paint over what 12 million
dollars for the Russian dossier full of
Russian lies where's the FBI where's the
CIA where the spies of course there
weren't any instead of investigating it
well they used former spy Christopher
Steele who they fired as a trusted
source and they used falls completely
unverified never corroborated a dossier
he put together to get a warrant and
then spy on the Trump campaign never
tell the judges she paid for it and in
the process lying to FISA Court judges
on four separate occasions never
revealing Hillary paid for all this this
is the biggest abuse of power corruption
scandal we have seen in the history of
this country
talk about Watergate this is Watergate
on steroids and human growth hormone
Watergate what a third-rate break-in
that eventually forced the President to
resign you may remember this to continue
to fight through the months ahead for my
personal vindication
would almost totally absorbed the time
and attention of both the president and
the Congress in a period when our entire
focus should be on the great issues of
peace abroad and prosperity without
inflation at home therefore I shall
resign the presidency effective at noon
tomorrow what is playing out right now
is nothing compared to Watergate spying
on an opposition party during an
election
it makes Watergate look like stealing a
candy bar from a candy store now here's
why now the details of this abuse of
power are so far worse the New York
Times now confirming this week
everything we have been telling you
The Times didn't all of a sudden decide
oh we want to tell people the truth this
is about actively now assisting the deep
state and what the Times is doing is
they're helping these bad actors get in
front of this scandal because they know
it's all coming out so they're twisting
and spinning the facts and crafting
their own narrative now to steal a page
from the FBI's playbook well they now
know crossfire hurricane is coming now
here's why the deep state is about to be
exposed it's all happening now a portion
of the DOJ IG report is set to come out
now in a couple of weeks Congress well
they'll eventually get the documents
that led up to the IG report we'll see
it all the DOJ is now slowly leaking
this information to friendly news
outlets like the Washington Post - New
York Times here's the thing what they're
now reporting is now corroborating
everything we have been uncovering let's
run through the details starting with
this quote the FBI obtained phone
records other documents using National
Security Letters a secret type of
subpoena officials said and at least one
government informant ie spy met several
times with mr. Page and mr. Papadopoulos
and current and former officials say
that confirms the FBI had a spy and
informant that infiltrated the Trump
campaign where's the warrant and in
addition to line to the four FISA
judges four times to get the FISA
warrant to spy on the Trump campaign the
FBI is using secret spies was there
another secret subpoena now it sounds
like the deep state was using every
single option available to go after the
Trump campaign and by the way after they
of course rigged the Hillary
investigation here's another significant
quote that matches our reporting days
after they closed their investigation
into Hillary Clinton's use of a private
email server agents began scrutinizing
the campaign of her Republican rival now
The Times adds that both these
investigations were made up of a small
group of the same top officials so the
same officials that rigged the Clinton
email investigation even though we know
she broke laws and obstructed justice
while then they went after Donald Trump
and set their sights on him now next now
is this shocking part that directly
implicates here John Kerry and Barack
Obama nobody's picked up on this Capo
Australian officials broke with
diplomatic protocol allowed the
Ambassador Alexander Downer to sit for
an FBI interview to describe his meeting
with campaign adviser George papadopolis
all right diplomatic protocol broken
that means John Kerry from the get-go
this is the beginning the Obama State
Department and I'm sure the president
that means Obama all involved that means
they knew about the spying from the
start and as we have been saying for
months John Kerry Barack Obama need to
answer two simple questions what did you
both know and when did you both know it
now these are there are other disturbing
details in this now these deep state
sources were revealed to the New York
Times at four Trump campaign associates
were being investigated by the FBI
wasn't just Carter page and joint
Papadopoulos whoever he is
the FBI was also going after General
Michael Flynn and Paul Manafort from the
get-go this was a major intelligence
operation and finally these unnamed
sources also tried to spin the Peter
struck Lisa page text messages you know
what they were talking about who we now
think is Andrew McCabe about their
so-called insurance policy in case the
unthinkable happened and Donald Trump
won the
claiming now quote they said that
anything the FBI did publicly would only
give fodder to mr. Trump's campaigns and
claims that the election was rigged
mr. struck countered that even if mr.
Trump's chances of victory were low like
dying before you're 40 the stakes are
too high to justify inaction
well that's laughable and it proves our
point the deep state these top players
not rank-and-file desperately trying to
spend all of this damning all of this
incriminating evidence now another new
breaking story to tell you about tonight
anonymous government sources have been
repeatedly leaking to the media details
about the FBI informant who did spy on
the Trump campaign and at the same time
they're accusing the president
Republicans even people like me of
putting this informants life in danger
I've known the guy's name for the full
week here's the latest example from the
Washington Post bigger than Watergate
Trump joins push by allies to expose the
role of an FBI source they are falsely
smearing not only the president and
congressional Republicans and yours
truly know we're trying to conduct an
investigation Congress is they have
constitutional oversight authority
they're supposed to do this in the
process Washington Post as biased as
they are is revealing key details about
who the person is for example quote the
source is a US citizen and it's provided
information over the years to both the
FBI and the CIA as the post previously
reported and aided the Russia
investigation both before and after
Muller's appointment in May of 2017
according to people familiar with his
activities okay on the face of this it's
ridiculous and for the record the
person's name has been out there in the
media I've known it for over a week and
by the way it's not some closely held
state secret what is withholding now or
unfolding before our eyes --is utter
insanity and the total hypocrisy on
display for the cold country to see you
got the DOJ FBI or accusing the
president Republicans people like me of
endangering a source at the same time
anonymous law enforcement intelligence
the ones leaking the details about who
the informant is that is what we call a
deliberative smear now here's point
number two this is really important
these unnamed federal officials have
leaked more information to the New York
Times and Washington Post then they've
given to Congress because they're trying
to get a friendly audience and remember
rod Rosenstein has been slow walking
obstructing stonewalling every
congressional attempt to do their
constitutional authority of oversight
every chance he gets and when Rosenstein
does actually comply while he turned
over what heavily redacted information
and the claims of national security but
we've seen that's just a lie it's not
true
look at these leaks about the FBI
informant you know what would they
really be doing all this if it was a
national security threat this is about
getting out in front of Congress in
front of the IG in front of what they
know is coming they're trying to control
the narrative slowly bleed it out has
nothing to do with national security
just like Rosenstein we're tackling the
fact that James Comey didn't think that
general Flynn lied to the FBI neither
did anyone else in the FBI that had
nothing to do with national security
that was a cya and Rosenstein protecting
his corrupt friends he and Jeff sessions
they either need to go or do their job
also tonight the president reacting to
this horrible shooting yes another sad
school shooting this time in Texas
earlier today let's take a look
unfortunately I have to begin by
expressing our sadness and heartbreak
over the deadly shooting at Santa Fe
High School in Texas this bears been
going on too long in our country too
many years too many decades now we
grieve for the terrible loss of life and
send our support and love to everyone
affected by this absolutely horrific
attack to the students families teachers
and personnel at Santa Fe
hi we're with you in this tragic hour
and we will be with you forever
very sad and this has to stop but our
prayers and thoughts do go to these
families in Texas they lost their
children trace calories Gallagher is
gonna have a full report in a few
minutes as we've been saying on this
program it is so far beyond time that
everything be done to protect our kids
in school it's simple we can solve this
this is not a political issue harden up
the schools every school in this country
needs a full threat security assessment
every school we've got to secure the
perimeter
and entry points of every school we must
require and mandate IDs for anybody that
walks into a school metal detectors in
every single school and we need to hire
retired concealed carry police officers
retired military members and we should
have two on every floor of every school
in America that's what I think is a
simple answer and here's an idea by the
way in case you're interested in new
ideas if these people work 15 hours
retired military retired police
concealed carry let's give them federal
state local tax breaks as incentives it
won't cost a lot of money it's not
political it shouldn't be political we
protect our athletes we protect our
politicians we protect those on the red
carpet how about we do this for our kids
let's do it in their best interests I'm
gonna more coming up later in the
program another disturbing scene sadly
to tell you about this one taking place
at Trump national Doral golf course
where police officers had to shoot a
deranged man in his legs earlier today
after he reported started yelling
anti-trump rhetoric and opened fire
inside of the resort police are saying
this lunatic wanted to lure officers
into an ambush-style attack thank God
they were able to stop this particular
nutcase